hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer question from
one of my form readers hurts web hosting
who wrote in asking about a content
management system so he wrote in the
poll saying I'm looking to integrate a
CMS content management system into an
existing website and would like the
options as to which program has the most
functionality WordPress Joomla or Drupal
so linked to the question a great
question for anybody setting up a
website and trying to grow it it's great
to use a content management system
instead of trying to do everything
yourself my opinion would be to use
WordPress and we've built our own custom
content management system this was built
just before WordPress became kind of
mainstream so we had almost no choice in
to do it ourselves but we also do have
WordPress on our site and have a couple
of blogs at a wordpress base there is
why I like WordPress a couple reasons
one it's really easy to set up you could
do most of the work yourself you'll
you'll need you know a couple of hours
of the programmers time just to do all
the implementation but apart from that
you could do everything yourself you can
add content yourself you can add
pictures yourself you can do whatever
you want mostly yourself a lot of the
plugins you can add yourself the updates
you can do yourself so a big challenge
for a lot of entrepreneurs is always
having to pay a web developer to help
them make updates to their website we're
here the power is in your hands we will
to update your website you know I'd
content to it make it look nice without
having to pay somebody time to do it if
you want to do a major upgrade then yes
you'd have to have somebody come on
board but for most of the stuff that
you're doing day-to-day you don't need
any help which is great big believe
we're not trying to spend a lot of money
such as you start in the business until
you're making money coming in WordPress
also has a lot of different themes so
you can pick a lot of different designs
is a lot that are free and a lot that
are really low cost so you're not
spending a lot of money to get a
professional looking design for your
your website as well and it's very
customizable so you can I've seen
WordPress sites that are
blogs which everybody knows about but
also forms and a whole bunch of
applications that you could turn and you
wouldn't think is WordPress base but it
is a whole community people who've
developed around WordPress think more so
than the other applications that give
you a lot of flexibility if you're
trying to expand your company and offer
a whole bunch of different content
levels on your website so i would
definitely use wordpress i think the
last thing there is there's a lot of
people who can get into wordpress really
easily to find a joomla person or a
drupal programmer it's a more specific
skill set I found then finding somebody
who can jump into WordPress so if you do
need to find a developer or your
developer JumpShip you have to go find
another developer it's pretty easy to
find somebody who can understand
wordpress and a lot of the tools are
already built so it's easy to you know
find those people in case something goes
wrong you need someone in a pinch to
really help you out that's I guess a
huge concern for a lot of entrepreneurs
you're not stuck the only certain people
because they have certain skill sets do
you want to make it as easy as possible
so if I was just starting today I would
probably make my entire website based on
WordPress and customize around it again
we you know started before WordPress
really became mainstream so we built our
own content management system from
scratch and are not going to scrap
everything now just to go to WordPress
but if I was starting over from now I'd
probably look at work press very
seriously instead of doing something
ourselves and customize around it
because a lot of the cool awesome tools
have already been built around it so
hopefully it helps that's my opinion if
you guys watching the video or and are
liking it please give it a thumbs up
that makes you want to do more of these
videos for you guys and I'd love to hear
what you're using if you have any extra
feedback that you can offer here and if
you have a question I'd also love to see
it if you want leave it in the comments
below so thank you and we'll see you on
the next episode
you